- Thanks to Ting Mobile for
keeping legal legal in the air.
In the waning days of
the Trump presidency,
people are wondering if president Trump
is going to exercise the pardon power
to pardon himself and his family.
Well, yeah, probably.
Good night everyone.
Oh, you want to know
if there are any limits
on the presidential pardon power,
or if there's anything that can be done
to stop the president using
the pardon power for himself
and potentially co-conspirators.
Well, the US Constitution
gives the president the power
to grant reprieves and pardons
for offenses against the United States,
except in cases of impeachment,
even pardon the Turkey.
- Drumstick.
You are here by pardoned.
- But could President
Trump pardon this Turkey?
Could he pardon his family
in potential co-conspirators?
Could he step down and
have President Mike Pence
pardon him before he leaves office?
(introductory music)
Hey LegalEagle, It's time
to think like a lawyer
for the president.
The pardon power is kind
of like a magic eraser
that sets aside punishment
for federal crimes.
But that doesn't mean that
there are no limits whatsoever
to the power to pardon.
The text of Article II, Section 2,
establishes a few
limitations to be broad grant
of pardon power.
For example, the pardon
power does not apply
to state crimes.
Why? Because the
constitution explicitly says
that, "the president may only give pardons
to offenses against the United States."
And that means federal crimes.
People often mistakenly
believe a president can pardon
or commute the sentences
of people convicted of state
crimes, but that can't be done.
People with state convictions have to look
to their governors for reprieve.
The pardon power also cannot be used
to set aside impeachment.
There is some disagreement
about what this really means,
but at a minimum, the president
cannot pardon an executive
or judicial officer from
an impeachment conviction.
In all likelihood, if President
Trump had been convicted
in the Senate, he could
not have pardoned himself
in order to remain in office.
And depending on how the
conviction was stylized
by the Senate and the particular
punishment that was given,
the conviction would
have immediately removed
the presidential power anyway.
But there's still some
ambiguity about the phrase
in cases of impeachment as a limit
on a presidential pardon power.
Especially for president pardons,
people who helped him
commit impeachable offenses.
Some people believe that
the constitution imposes
other limits on the pardon power.
They generally pointed
the president's Article II
duties to faithfully execute the laws.
When a president takes the oath of office,
he or she must affirm their
commitment to the rule of law.
So we could argue that a
president who pardons himself
has co-conspirators or
accepts favors in exchange
for pardons is not
faithfully executing the laws
or the duties of the office as a whole.
These arguments certainly make sense,
but they're completely untested
and could be completely unconstitutional.
The most common response would probably be
that if a president is acting
as if they're above the law,
then the remedy is impeachment
and the founders wrote
at least one limitation
into the pardon power.
If they wanted to write more,
they could have put in
those limitations directly
into the document.
But let's take a step back
and talk about the origins
of pardon power.
And the pardon power was adopted
from an English tradition
known as the Royal
Prerogative of English Kings,
which gave the King the ability
to overturn any sentence.
It might seem counterintuitive
that the American founders
adopted the pardon
since they had just revolted
against King George III,
because they thought
he had too much power.
And James Madison wrote that,
"giving one person legislative, executive
and judicial powers was the
very definition of tyranny."
So why does the constitution
give the president the ability
to quickly reverse a court's judgment?
Well, ask Alexander Hamilton,
who argued that the pardon power
was a tool a president could use
to swiftly diffuse tensions
during times of national crisis.
George Washington immediately
use the pardon power
to end the Whiskey Rebellion.
And giving the tax
protesting farmers a pardon
rather than sentencing them to death
actually worked out pretty well.
But Hamilton trusted the pardon
because he thought it would be used only
by the most virtuous of men.
But we are a long, long way
from George Washington now.
But one of the issues
that perennially comes up,
especially in the context
of a potential Trump pardon
is whether a pardon is
an admission of guilt.
If someone accepts a
pardon, does he or she admit
that they were guilty
of the underlying crime?
Whether accepting a pardon
is an admission of guilt under the law
is actually an open question.
In the 1800s after the Civil
War in Ex parte Garland,
the Supreme Court said that,
"a pardon blots out
the existence of guilt,
so that in the eyes of
the law the offender
is as innocent as if he'd
never committed the offense."
This sentence suggests
that a pardon wipes away
any person's guilt,
yet the court seemed to back
off of this interpretation
in the 1915 case, Burdick
versus the United States.
In Burdick, the court
observed that a confession
of guilt may be implied in
the acceptance of a pardon.
But Burdick was about whether a recipient
could turn down a pardon.
As some have argued, the court meant
that as a practical matter,
because pardons make people look guilty.
A recipient might not want to accept one,
but arguably pardons have
no formal legal effect
of declaring guilt.
In fact, many people have been
granted pardon specifically,
because they're innocent.
There isn't much case
law directly on point,
but recent lower court cases seem to align
with Burdick statement
that a person admits guilt
when they accept a pardon.
President George H.W Bush
pardoned Elliott Abrams
for his role in the Iran-Contra scandal.
But the DC bar initiated
disciplinary proceedings
against Abrams for lying to Congress
during its investigation of that scandal.
Abrams challenged the
proceedings on the grounds
that the pardon not only erased
his criminal convictions,
but it meant he couldn't
be sanctioned by the bar
for lying under oath.
The DC circuit disagreed holding,
"because a pardon does not blot out guilt,
one can conclude that a pardon
does not blot out probable cause
or guilt, or expungement indictment."
So the pardon didn't force the DC bar
to treat Abrams as lying under oath
is something that never happened.
But could the president issue a pardon
that is so open-ended and broad
that it doesn't actually
specify who the recipient is?
Could a president issue a mass pardon
to all people who meet certain criteria?
The answer to that is probably yes,
there's no limitation on broad pardons.
For example, Andrew Johnson pardoned
all ex Confederate soldiers in 1868.
Benjamin Harrison, pardoned all
members of the Mormon church
who had committed polygamy.
And Jimmy Carter, pardoned
all who had evaded
the Vietnam War in 1977.
So if historical precedent
is any indication,
if President Trump wanted to pardon,
let's say every person who
had ever been convicted
of a federal drug crime,
he could probably do it.
He does not have to specify
each individual person by name.
But by the same token,
he could probably specify
that anyone involved
in any crime related to the "Russia Hoax"
could also receive a pardon
and effectively end
investigations of that.
Which brings us to another one
of the perennial questions about pardons,
which is can a president
grant a perspective pardon
where there's been no conviction
or even indictment for a crime?
We expect President Trump
to issue many pardons
on his way out of office.
But can he pardon people
who have yet to be indicted
or even investigated for a federal crime?
And the answer to that is a
clear, yes, he can do that.
It appears that the
president can issue a pardon
before any criminal proceeding
against that person has been initiated.
This is a prospective pardon.
And in the 1866 case, Ex parte Garland
that we just talked about,
the Supreme Court announced
that the pardon power,
"extends to every offense known to the law
and may be exercised at the
time after its commission,
either before legal proceedings are taken,
or during the pendency or
after conviction and judgment."
This basically means that
the president only needs
to know a crime has been committed.
He doesn't have to wait until
after the authorities indict
or arrest a person in order
to grant them a pardon.
The most famous perspective pardon
is when President Gerald
Ford pardoned Richard Nixon
for, "all offenses
against the United States,
which he has committed
or may have committed
or taken part in during the period
from January 20th, 1969
through August 9th, 1974."
Nixon had not been indicted for any crimes
and resigned before he
could even be impeached.
The pardon shielded him
from any future prosecution
based on any criminal
acts he might've committed
during his time specified in the pardon.
But that takes us to a more
insidious potentials situation,
a quid pro quo pardon.
The phrase quid pro quo,
as you probably now know
is something for something
or give and take.
So can a president dole out pardons
to people who offer him gifts, money,
or other things of value?
Well, the law at 18 U.S.C 201
makes it illegal to
bribe a public official.
Now it's an open question,
whether it applies to the president.
But putting that aside for the moment,
the bribery statute doesn't necessarily
make a quid pro quo pardon illegal.
In 2020, the House Democrats
introduced legislation
that would make it illegal for a president
to give a pardon in exchange
for something of value.
The same proposed legislation
also made it illegal
for a president to pardon himself.
Although it's sort of an open question,
whether this law itself
would be constitutional.
The Congress can't pass
a law that conflicts
with the constitution itself.
Interestingly, Bill Barr,
yes, that Bill Barr,
is on record as saying that a
president who sells a pardon
is guilty of a crime, quid pro quo crime.
- Do you believe a president
could lawfully issue a pardon
in exchange for the recipient's promise
to not incriminate him?
- No, that would be a crime.
- And he went on to
say that if a president
gave away a pardon in
exchange for someone's silence
that could be obstruction of justice.
- Oh, a quid pro quo to change testimony
could potentially be obstruction.
- And that makes sense because
there's plenty of things
that someone can do as
a governmental employee
that you're authorized to do,
but under certain
circumstances can be illegal.
For example, if your job is
to sell military equipment
if you choose to sell military
equipment to North Korea.
Well you're authorized to do
it but it can still be a crime.
And selling a pardon as president
is one of those classic
examples that you use to say
that yes, the president has that authority
but there are circumstances
that can give rise
to illegality.
Now query what would happen
under those circumstances
in terms of whether the pardon
would still be in effect or not.
These are things that
would need to be litigated
and hopefully they'll
never need to be litigated.
But the bottom line is
that the most likely remedy
for a quid pro quo pardon
is probably impeachment,
not criminal prosecution.
And speaking of quid pro quo.(laughs)
I was checking my YouTube stats
and only 30% of this audience
is subscribed to this channel.
So if you're getting value,
the quid from this channel,
please subscribe and
hit the bell, the quo.
And as the president says,
but first I'd like you
to do me this favor.
Which takes us to the question
of whether the president
can pardon his own family.
And the answer there is probably yes.
There's no law or rule
that says President Trump can't
pardon his family members.
In 2001, former President Bill Clinton
pardoned his brother,
Roger, who was convicted
for cocaine possession in Arkansas.
But there's nothing in the
text of the constitution
or the case law surrounding
the pardon power
that would seem like it would limit
President Trump's ability to
pardon members of his family,
whether it appears proper or not.
But if you're talking about
President Trump's family
that's a natural segue way to the question
of whether the president can
pardon his co-conspirators.
President Trump has been
implicated in many federal crimes
that took place before
and after he took office.
We've done several videos
about that in the past.
And in one particular instance,
President Trump's former
lawyer and fixer, Michael Cohen
was sentenced to three years in prison
for several crimes, including
using campaign funds
to pay off women who had
affairs with the president.
Federal Judge, William H
Pauley III said in open court
that Trump had directed Cohen
to commit a federal felony.
Trump was referred to in this proceedings
as individual number one and
unindicted co-conspirator.
And that's just one particular instance.
There are lots of the
president's associates
who have been implicated in crimes
that he was either
involved in or directed.
Can the president pardon these people?
Well, it's certainly
possible that President Trump
will pardon people who are
considered his co-conspirators.
And I hate to tell you, but
it's actually happened before.
In 1987, an independent counsel
was investigating crimes
committed by members of
the Reagan Administration
for violating federal law
by selling weapons to Iran.
And then illegally funneling the money
to Contras in Nicaragua.
- For 18 months now,
we have had underway a secret
diplomatic initiative to Iran.
- For all you kids out there,
this was the Iran-Contra scandal.
Attorney General William Barr,
yes, that Bill BARR helped
President George H.W Bush
stop this investigation
by pardoning six people,
including former Defense
Secretary, Caspar Weinberger,
who was about to go on trial
to face charges about lying to Congress.
So you can chalk this one
up to the pardon power
being very, very broad.
There's probably nothing
that would stop the president
from pardoning people
who have committed crimes
at the president's own behest.
And of course the first but
not the last lame duck pardon
has been given to former
general Michael Flynn
in an insanely broad pardon.
I've covered the Michael Flynn situation
in the past in a different
video, you can check that out.
But many people are
outraged by the Flynn pardon
and what arguably makes this different
from some of President
Trump's other pardons
is that the criminal
conduct lying to the FBI
was arguably designed to
protect President Trump himself
from prosecution or impeachment.
So here we have Trump pardoning a person
who may have helped him
hide his criminal conduct.
Does this actually matter though,
when it comes to assessing the
legality of the Flynn burden?
Probably not.
Although law professors
like Mark Ostler have said
the Flynn pardon is a despicable
use of an awesome power.
Even he agrees that this is
part of the broad expression
of the pardon power presidents enjoy.
That to be clear, this
is bad news for democracy
if a president can use
pardons the way a mafia don
would wield them as a
carrot to ensure loyalty
from the don soldiers.
But if you have a problem with
it, amend the constitution.
No, seriously, amend the constitution.
President Trump could
pardon Jared Kushner's dad,
Steve Bannon, Paul Manafort,
and even Rudy Giuliani,
who's allegedly being investigated
for breaking lobbying laws.
But does Congress just have
to sit back and take it?
Can Congress investigate
the use of a pardon?
Although Congress probably lacks
direct legislative authority
to limit the pardon power
via federal statute,
it does have other constitutional
tools for regulating
and overseeing the
president's pardon authority.
Congress has the right to
use its oversight powers
to investigate.
They can issue subpoenas and hold hearings
on the matters of presidential pardons.
Admittedly, it's sort of an
open question in this era
just how powerful
congressional subpoenas are,
and whether Congress has the ability
to enforce those subpoenas
against the executive.
But I suspect that out of the wash
the courts will affirm Congress's ability
to enforce subpoenas
into matters like these.
And when President Bill Clinton
pardoned about 450 people
at the end of his second term,
Republicans and Congress were outraged.
And many of these pardons
were controversial,
such as his pardon of Democratic
party donor, Marc Rich,
who had fled the country
because of tax evasion charges.
But congressional committees
held oversight hearings
to assess whether these pardons were
for lack of a better word, bad.
But the bottom line was that
even if the pardons looked bad
or rewarded people who had
connections to President Clinton,
Congress lacked the authority
to do anything about
whatever it uncovered.
Although presidents have
complied with subpoenas
and witnesses have testified.
The Department of Justice has said
that such compliance was voluntary
and could not necessarily
be compelled by a court.
It would certainly be
an interesting test case
for the Supreme Court,
which has expressed some
skepticism about the scope
of how subpoenas into President
Trump's financial records.
But it seems like it has to
be the case that if the remedy
for improper use of a
pardon is impeachment,
then Congress has to have the ability
to investigate the use of those pardons.
But that takes us to the penultimate issue
with respect to pardons.
Which is, what would happen if
President Trump stepped down
and allowed Mike Pence to pardon him?
Many people wonder if Donald
Trump could resign at 11:59 AM
on January the 20th, making
Mike Pence the president
for just a few minutes,
just long enough to
pardon President Trump.
Yes, this is the scenario that led
to Gerald Ford's pardon of Richard Nixon.
For years, people have claimed that Nixon
and Ford made a deal
that Nixon would resign
if Ford agreed to pardon him.
This sounds like a sleazy deal,
but there doesn't seem to be
any evidence of wrongdoing
or shady dealing by Ford.
But at the end of the day,
Trump could effectively
do the same thing instead
of leaving office two
years before his term
is up as Richard Nixon did.
Trump could effectively step down
with just a few minutes
left in his presidency,
turn it over to Mike Pence
and ask for a pardon from
President Mike Pence.
Of course, President
Trump has already stated
that he could pardon himself.
So he doesn't actually need to do that.
But the question is,
can the president actually pardon himself?
President Trump certainly
thinks he has that power.
He said on more than one occasion,
"I have the absolute
right to pardon myself."
But it's an open question,
because obviously no one
has ever done this before.
So it's uncharted territory.
And as with most things
with constitutional law.
First, we look to the
text of the constitution.
And as we've discussed,
the constitution gives
the president the power
to grant reprieves and pardon
for offenses against the United States,
except in cases of impeachment.
So at first blush, it
doesn't contain a limitation
that says, unless you are the President
of the United States.
But that's not necessarily
the end of the question.
In particular, because
I think a lot of people
consider the idea of a
president pardoning him
or herself to be so odious.
Another prudential argument
is that if the president
could pardon himself,
he would forever be above the law.
Many believe that a sitting
president cannot be indicted.
If the president could pardon himself
before he leaves office,
he'd be immune from all
federal crimes while in office
and then forever when he leaves.
And in at least one part
of the constitution,
the framers clearly
intended criminal penalties
after office.
Article I, Section 3 declares,
"judgment in cases of impeachment
shall not extend further
than to removal from office
and disqualification to
hold and enjoy any office
of honor, trust or profit
on the United States.
But the party convicted
shall nevertheless be liable
and subject to indictment,
trial, judgment and punishment,
according to law."
Many argue that the constitution says that
the Congress may not
impose criminal penalties
on a president, but the president
is still nonetheless subject
to federal criminal prosecution
through ordinary courts
and allowing a self
pardon would eviscerate
that clause of the constitution.
And one of the canons of construction,
the rule against surplusage
would lend credence to the idea
that a self-dealing pardon is void.
Other strict textualist
argue that the plain meaning
of the pardon clause
doesn't actually allow
for a self-dealing pardon,
specifically because of the word, grant,
as it's used in that clause.
The constitution says,
"the president shall have
power to grant reprieves
and pardons for offenses
against the United States."
The grant of a pardon
implies the transferring
of one thing to another.
The constitution uses the
word, grant five other times,
always in the context of one person
or body granting something
to another person or body.
For example, Article I says,
"the legislative power herein
granted shall be vested
in the Congress of the United States."
Here the people of the United States
are granting Congress
the right to make laws.
Also, Article I says, "Congress may grant
letters of mark and reprisal."
This man Congress can give private ships
the right to start wars
against ships of other nations.
This was an important grant
of power back in the day
since it protected private vessels
against accusations of piracy.
Notice again, that Congress
is transferring a thing,
letters of mark and
reprisal to another entity.
It seems to imply to people
or at least a separate grantor
and the grantee, kind
of like a kidney donor.
You can have the power to give a kidney
but you can't give it to yourself.
LegalEageley speaking,
that's not a good idea,
but I'm skeptical of this argument.
For one, regular people and lawyers
do use grants in a reflexive way.
For example in property law,
a person might grant him
or herself an easement
or a life estate.
A life estate is a property
that an individual owns
only through the duration
of their lifetime.
You don't see life estates all that often,
but I assure you they do exist.
And law students hate them
because they make property
law really complicated
and annoying.
But the point is you can
grant yourself a life estate.
So it's not clear which
way this argument would go.
Which is one of the reasons why
the Office of Legal
Counsel of the White House
has opined on this particular
issue several times.
And there's a general principle in U.S law
that a person cannot be the
judge in their own case.
Which would argue against
the president being able
to pardon him or herself.
And in 1974, when President Nixon
asked the Office of Legal Counsel, the OLC
to determine if he could pardon himself,
the OLC relied on that principle
in saying that President Nixon
could not pardon himself.
And in the famous August
5th, 1974 memo of the OLC,
Mary Lawton, the acting
assistant attorney general wrote,
"under the fundamental rule
that no one may be the judge
in their own case, the president
cannot pardon himself."
And four days later,
Nixon resigned in disgrace
possibly because he didn't think
that he was legally
allowed to pardon himself.
So given the President Nixon staff opined
that he could not pardon himself,
and often people complain that the OLC
is really beholden to the presidency
and aren't really giving
objective opinions.
And even Nixon himself would not go so far
to issue a self pardon.
That's potentially persuasive authority
that the president doesn't
have the power to self pardon.
And there is some authority
from the Supreme Court
that's persuasive because the
Supreme Court hasn't ruled
on this precise issue of the
president pardoning himself.
So it's not dispositive, but
it might help in this analysis.
There's really only one Supreme
Court case that's on point,
and that is Ex parte
Garland case from 1866,
which we've talked about now
twice in this same video,
because there aren't that many cases.
And the Ex parte Garland case
concerned Congress's ability
to exclude members of the Confederacy
from practicing federal
law after the Civil War
and whether the president could pardon
a Confederate soldier.
Again, going back to the idea
of whether the pardon expunges everything,
or whether there's some remaining residue
from the prior crimes
that have been committed.
And the Supreme Court held five to four
that the president could
pardon the Confederate Senator.
But more importantly, the
court held unanimously
that the Supreme Court has the authority
to interpret the scope
of the pardon power.
And like the bedrock Supreme Court case
of Marbury versus Madison,
Ex parte Garland is
probably less important
for the actual outcome of the case.
Then for the principle
that the Supreme Court
has the overview authority
to interpret the constitution
in this case and make a
decision one way or the other
about the president's pardon power.
So this probably means
that if President Trump
tried to pardon himself,
he could do it in the first instance.
He might be able to file
the paperwork for himself,
but under a Supreme Court case law,
the Supreme Court has the
power to review that pardon.
And it's possible that the Supreme Court
could review the case and actually nullify
the president's self pardon
on the grounds that the
president cannot be the judge
in his own case or that the
impeachment exception applies,
which prevents the president's pardon
from going into effect.
But the Ex parte Garland
case was 150 years ago.
So there's no telling that
the current Supreme Court
is actually even going
to take up the case.
But the way that you would test it
is if a certain president pardoned himself
and then a new president
whether a prosecutor
or the attorney general
himself decided to indict
and move forward with charging
that president with a crime.
Well, that former president
would then be able
to challenge the
prosecution on the grounds
that he had received and
granted his own pardon.
And that would certainly go all the way up
to the Supreme Court, almost guaranteed.
It's possible that if
a case did make its way
up to the Supreme Court and query
who even has standing
to bring this challenge
to the president's self pardon
that the court would look at it and say,
"look, this is a political question."
We've seen the modern Supreme Court punt
on a lot of questions claiming
this is a political question
left for the legislative
and executive branches,
and the separation of powers.
And that there's a roundy
in the constitution
that the president can be impeached
and removed even up to
the last day in office.
So if people find his behavior so odious,
they can impeach him and
remove him from office.
And that is the political
resolution to all of these things.
So there's no telling what
a Supreme Court would do,
whether they would follow
the guidance of the OLC,
which is not binding precedent
or whether they would allow
the self pardon to stand.
Of course, if President Trump is indicted,
he'll need to call it a
good lawyer from jail.
No, I said a good lawyer.
Well, I guess he's obviously going to have
to make a bunch of phone calls.
And the best way to make those phone calls
is with Ting Mobile.
Ting Mobile has three brand new plans.
You can get talking texts
for only $10 a month.
Data plans starting at $15,
five gigabytes for $25
and unlimited for $45.
Switching plans is actually really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and use pretty much any phone.
And the service is great too,
because Ting partners with
several massive networks.
Very possibly the same one
you're using right now,
but at a huge discount.
Contractually, I can't tell you which ones
because I always respect contracts.
But I've mentioned them before
and you can almost see
them over the horizon.
So whether you use two gigabytes
or 20 gigabytes a month,
there's a perfect Ting plan
for you and your family.
And if you're around Wi-Fi all the time,
which most of us are considering
we're working from home.
You have the flexibility to
save hundreds of dollars.
I wonder if federal jails have Wi-Fi,
but Ting gives you the option
to pay only for what you use
because Ting's Flex Plan
gives you the option
to just pay for what you use.
It's a smarter, cheaper
version of the same plan
that they've always had.
Now they're just adding
unlimited versions as well.
So if you want unlimited data, go crazy.
So if you go to legaleagle.ting.com,
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save.
And Legal Eagles will
also get a $25 credit
that could cover two months of service.
So just click on the
link in the description
or go to legaleagle.ting.com,
and plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Believe your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews,
where I talk about all the
crazy stuff that's happening
in the waning days of
the Trump presidency.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.